j'ai passé des moments exceptionnels
avec eric zemmour pour la démocratie
pour apprendre le débat pour apprendre
la rhétorique pour apprendre les
arguments par exemple et je pense que
cette histoire justement de face à
l'info dans l'histoire de l'audiovisuel
français restera pourquoi parce que la
case par exemple quand je présente
aujourd'hui a été multiplié par dix en
audience bien sûr parce que il ya des
téléspectateurs qui sont venus en masse
comme ce soir comme à chaque fois il
passe à la radio à la télévision et a
toujours un record d'audience donc c'est
intéressant de vivre de l'intérieur ça
n'a pas été facile ça n'a pas été facile
on est perdu mais beaucoup de cheveux
devant alors je ne vois pas vous êtes
magnifique du mascaret connu mais j'ai
beaucoup et j'ai voilà exactement
c'était difficile moi j'aimerais
j'aimerais que les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent ce soit en direct eric
zemmour c'est c'est le candidat à la
présidentielle ce soir qu'on soit on
aimerait aussi savoir comment il est
avant les émissions après les émissions
est-ce que comment ça se passe avec lui
oui donc je disais je termine en disant
que c'était émotionnellement difficile
par moments mais s'était rattrapé
justement par l'ambiance toujours en
tard il sait pas arrivé à l'heure il est
alors aujourd'hui un ravin on a dû le
préciser
il sera l'heure du générique en fait
d'accord mais comment il est un puits de
connaissances
regardez une a pas de notes tout le
monde a des notes il n'a pas de notes
dans tous les débats entre potes
non un puits de connaissances toujours
souriant il est sérieux sans se prendre
au sérieux et lorsqu'on travaille du
coup ensemble c'est très agréable j'ai
rencontré beaucoup j'ai fait beaucoup
d'émissions dans ma vie où c'était pas
forcément avec cette ambiance familiale
où on rigole alors je suis pas comme
eric naulleau je suis pas son ami je
suis pas je n'ai jamais déjeuné avec lui
je n'ai jamais dîné avec lui il m'a
jamais dragué
non mais c'est en sortant je dis tout je
dis ah c'est pas c'est quelqu'un avec
qui j'ai eu beaucoup de manques c'est
pour ça que je suis très claire de la
façon dont je parlais je n'ai pas deux
ni animosité ni complaisance c'est à
dire que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui a été correct avec moi droit avec
moi intelligent qui cache sa sensibilité
et ce à son affectivité son affection un
peu comme le disait emmanuel macron
heures soit il dit qu'il était très
affectif et le cash il pareil il est
très sensible et ils le cachent pour
pourvoir maintenant l'impression qu'il
va me faire trop au scope dans un
songe
à des tests l'horoscope
mais est aussi c'est quelqu'un et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pu travailler avec lui
c'est quelqu'un qui dise aussi l'homme
de ses idées et ça c'est un fait c'est à
dire ça semble assez capitale ce que ça
t'a dit au capot parce que vous vous
n'hésitez pas lui on lui dira d'ailleurs
vous étiez pas d'accord avec lui sur
plein de sujets vous lui disiez
d'ailleurs dans l'émission pour
lentilles etc ils disent aussi l'homme
de ses idées ça veut dire quoi pour le
téléspectateur c'est à dire qu'on peut
rigoler sans être d'accord qu'on peut on
peut discuter sans est d'accord c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on n'est pas bio
quelqu'un n'est pas d'accord avec lui on
y va pour en avoir envie de battre yb
avait envie de discuter ce qu'ils
achètent vous convaincre de rejoindre
ses idées ou pas du tout rigaud ou bien
ils voulaient savoir n'a pas beaucoup eu
l'occasion de discuter lui et moi en
tête à tête je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
ceni pour qui je vote mais si je suis
patriote ou mondialistes nice je suis de
gauche ou de droite ça s'y intéressent à
moi non plus je ne sais pas
et je mets en touche comme éric lui des
années et vous voyez je mets un point
d'honneur à ce que l'on ne sache pas
pour qui je veux ce que je pense et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui on a oublié
justement cette liberté j'ai trouvé par
exemple que lorsque j'ai commencé à
travailler avec ses mots tout de suite
j'ai catégoriser mes amis ceux qui
étaient justement qu'il ne savait pas
dissocier c'est ça les idiots ya
beaucoup de gens est très jeune et de
eric zemmour il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont tourné le dos à christine bien sûr
beaucoup de mines oui bien sûr et je
vois le niveau d'intelligence et
scellant jeudi qu'il mettait des gens
super ya à ce niveau là c'est à dire il
sait qu'on soit d'accord ou pas il va
rigoler avec vous il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ils me disent même pas
bonjour parce que j'ai travaillé avec
eric zemmour je veux dire je veux bien
qu'il soit nauséabonde j'en avais jean
ferrat
en fait au début j'en ai souffert et
après je me suis rendu compte que c'est
un niveau d'intelligence qui est juste
inférieur alors vous avez perdu des
alizés dit quoi il mais il méritait pas
hissé volaille qu'ils ont rien compris
oui ce sont des gens qui sont tombés
dans la caricature du personnage et et
dans la caricature je prends encore un
exemple de d'emmanuel manqueront il ya
ça qui dès qu'on est dans un monde delà
des constats que j'ai bien aimé emmanuel
macron hier soir beaucoup avant tout le
monde déteste moi j'aime à penser vous
allez pour emmanuel macron à sa personne
ne sait mais non mais je veux dire que
par exemple il a dit aussi voilà que
connaît dans un monde de
décontextualisation eric zemmour sur mon
plateau avait expliqué et argumentaire
aujourd'hui vous pouvez faire le
décompte toutes les 5 ou 10 secondes il
est interrompu on ne peut pas entendre
son argument c'est bien c'est le
sélectionneur médiatique aujourd'hui ses
sorties médiatiques aujourd'hui alors
justement et eric zemmour vous avez
travaillé christine kelly quand on vous
a dit vous allez faire équipe avec
christine kelly tous les jours vous la
connaissiez vous donnons d'accord vous
avez tout de suite dit oui oui comment
ça s'est passé la première rencontre
tout de suite vous avez vous avez eu ma
part annoncé que c'était tendu la
première fois vous savez l'émission
était très difficile à faire on était
contestée on avait des gens
manifestaient da qui manifestaient
dehors des deux des partis quand ça vous
ça vous a soumis ce qu'ils boycottaient
la chaîne et l'émission donc je vous
voulez oui s'étaient servies aux assurés
ça vous a pas plus tôt sous des mètres
dans une situation par là le premier
jour on essayait de trouver nos marques
chacun s'est mis à part ça n'est pas
simple à la première semaine et puis
après petit à petit on s'est croisés
avance et croisée après comme elle dit
on a commencé à rigoler vous l'avez
invite la botte meeting le signe qu'elle
n'était pas là je les ai invités mais
elle n'était pas d'accord la mairie
ouais vous étiez pas là j'étais à la
montagne avec des embauches au passo
voire
même même si je serai à paris je serais
pas allé je suis journal le reste dans
mon rôle de journaliste mais ça
n'empêche ça n'empêche pas du tout que
que j'ai du respect pour l'être humain
et je pourrai reese est mort et je
dissocie vraiment lui et ses idées et
pour travailler avec lui j'ai fait
exactement comme lui parce que c'est à
dire que quand quand il donne son
idéologie qui n'est pas forcément la
mienne je n'ai pas le prendre pour moi
est d'être à fleur de peau il ya réagir